[Music]
this weekend the country mourns together
as we mark the 21st anniversary of the 9
11 terror attacks the 9 11 memorial and
museum here in new york displays the
faces names and stories of the nearly 3
000 victims but two photos of the fallen
were missing adriana diaz has a story of
how a museum employee there made it his
personal mission to track down one of
the missing faces discovering the life
of a man we lost too soon in the tragedy
where the towers once stood
there's a constant flow of sorrow the
names of those lost here lined the
water's edge while just below ground
inside the 911 memorial and museum you
can look into their eyes i mean
everybody's face has a story behind it
says betty young and who made the famous
call
to the ground reporting the hijacking
underway jan seidla ramirez is the
museum's chief curator she's overseeing
the massive collection of these images
supplied by loved ones who volunteered
photos it sets up immediately the
diversity of the victims the magnitude
when people are in the gallery they will
go to the wall and they will find faces
that intrigue them what intrigued grant
yara who works in visitor services
helping guests was this missing photo
for albert ogletree one of two images
unaccounted for
he then made a promise to his friend in
security i pointed out the leaf and i
said to linda i said linda i'm going to
get the photo on the wall but little was
known about ogletree except that he
worked in a cafeteria in the north tower
his wife died after the attacks and he
had no known descendants
then on his own time yara found an
online tribute from a step-daughter he
tracked her down on facebook she did
write back to me however she did not
have any photos because
he did not like having his photo taken
he was camera shy he was people
associated with forte foods who were
food handlers they didn't have
the backing of an employer like the new
york city police department that had all
the different ways people
are photographed as part of a community
or as part of their employment so the
trail had run dry or did it
so i turned to ancestry.com and i was
able to find an address for him living
in romulus michigan i felt that maybe if
i could find where he went to high
school that maybe they would have a
photo of him this was really a shot in
the dark yes it was he emailed the high
school in romulus outside detroit they
didn't have older yearbooks but city
councilwoman and former teacher kathy
abdo who the school called for help knew
where to find them the local historical
museum i had an idea of what decade he
was in romulus so i went over and i went
through all of the yearbooks in the 60s
so i had to go through
page by page and that's where i found
albert ogletree the image is pixelated
but the camera shy ogletree is finally
found his only known photo taken around
15 years old this is someone that used
to go to my high school
and
he's not going to be forgotten now i'd
say i probably jumped a foot
you jumped a foot in the air yeah it was
a true
accomplishment
for albert for his memory to physically
hold it and see this sort of tender
sweet young face that you know the
adult life had not etched yet the really
wonderful moment was when the
step-daughter looked at the portrait and
she said oh my gosh he hasn't changed at
all we spoke to albert's step-daughter
and she said he taught me how to ride a
bike he helped teach me how to tie my
shoes she didn't want to appear on
camera but i can only imagine that this
is going to provide her with some kind
of closure
absolutely
the wide eyes and slight smile of a
young albert ogletree now appear above
his name
the details of his life are still
unclear but his face is in focus when
albert's photo went up i'm like linda
it's here i was like
wonderful
wonderful a promise made to a man from
the past he never knew
that he would never be
for cbs saturday morning adriana diaz
new york
that's taking those words never be
forgotten and actually putting it into
action yeah what a great story it really
was it really was and and her reaction
especially when yes and all of those
people are owning a piece of we've got
to find it a stranger a strong company
right